and a call now for some tough new
consequences for those in the lockdown
hypocrisy hall of fame
like the mayor of austin who was on a
mexican vacation when he told his
constituents
to stay home to stop the spread of kovid
he did say that he was sorry for that
but my next guest says
the apology just does not go far enough
and is not good enough governor mike
huckabee here in his own words the
former arkansas
governor and fox news contributor joins
us now governor it was
it was tough to take a lot of those
instances of hypocrisy
does sorry cut it
no it doesn't and i'll tell you why
because a lot of people have lost their
jobs
a lot of the people whose kids are
having to stay home from school they're
missing their work because they can't
go to work they have to stay home and
take care of kids whose schools are
closed
this hypocrisy is terrible but you know
who hadn't missed a single paycheck
people working in government city state
federal they all got every paycheck
here's what we need to do these mayors
and governors who have ordered people
to miss their jobs let them take a pay
cut
let them do without their pay for a
month and say i'm not going to ask you
to do something
that i'm not willing to do that'd be one
thing and
the fact is the the just glaring
hypocrisy
what it reveals is this sandra these
people don't believe in a lockdown
they don't believe that social
distancing and wearing a mask works
because if it did they'd be doing it
instead they just want to impose these
restrictions on other people
personally i do believe that we ought to
be wearing masks in social distancing
and and i'm not ordering other people to
do it i'm doing it because it's the
right thing to do
these folks who are ordering it but not
doing it they should resign
but i i and governor i think so many
people watching and listening to you
right now they agree we're all trying to
do what we can
to stay safe but you see the shattering
of lives
and businesses that is happening right
now and again another multi-week
shutdown
in california and then to have admiral
gerard on this program say
that there's no science behind the
outdoor restaurant
shut down he didn't say that that that
needs to happen
it's not essential to stop the spread to
shut down the outdoor dining
what is going on here
i think it's not about controlling the
virus it's about controlling the
population
it's about people exhibiting their power
and being power
crazy and the sad thing is a lot of
people are just going along with it
in california churches were told they
couldn't have more than 10 people in the
church
now you could go to a strip club i
jokingly suggested on sean hannity's
program that pastors ought to
stand up and say they're going to open a
strip club for church
strip off their tie in the middle of the
sermon and have as many people as they
wanted
some california pastors actually did
that rob mccoy
at godspeak calvary chapel in thousand
oaks it was hilarious but it made the
point
if you're going to say that it's so
dangerous to have more than 10 people
than be consistent
and that's not what's happening and i
hear this all the time
let's listen to the science okay let's
listen to the science
and the science doesn't tell us that
outdoor dining is really harmful
so why are we doing it because there's
some government bureaucrat or elected
official
who has it in his head that he's a
prince and everybody else is a peasant
and it's disgusting it's immoral and
it's certainly not how we're supposed to
be as a country where our public
servants are to serve us
not us serve them governor
we have a sort of a list
of those who made the hall of fame for
the hypocrisy that we've kind of kept
track of of course there was a story
with gavin newsom the governor of
california
who was seen pictured in that fancy
restaurant french laundry days later the
san francisco mayor
who was days later imposing tough new
restrictions
was there seated at the very same
restaurant we talked about the austin
mayor
but governor i hear you say you're
shocked by how many people just go along
with these tough restrictions but what
are people supposed to do
i mean they want to abide by the law
they don't want to get hit by fines
they won't want to be troublemakers but
they want to do the right thing so what
are you suggesting by that
well i suggest that they do uh what
they believe is the right thing they're
they're free americans
you know we're not living under tyranny
here i think some people may feel like
that we're coming to that
but be responsible as i said before i'm
taking all the steps that
we're told to take but i'm not doing it
because some tyrant is telling me i have
to
i'm doing it because i want to protect
myself my family my friends and the
people i bump into
i don't have to be ordered to do it but
people ought to have some freedom in
this country
and especially when it comes to going to
church
it's ridiculous to say that you can go
to a big box store and bump shoulders
with
hundreds of total strangers and touch
the items that they just touched
but you can't go to church and sit and
sing a hymn because that
might end up being way worse than going
to a strip club a casino
or a big discount store it just makes no
sense at all there's got to be
consistency
the fact that there isn't is causing
people to become
cynical that's that's a real public
health risk when we get cynical
and we don't believe anything our
government officials tell us
and the motions are running so high
we're about to get this update on this
bar
owner who's defying the tough
restrictions in the new york city area
staten island um that bar owner who we
have
tracked for quite some time his story
getting arrested for defying the
restrictions and
i mean you just wonder what
point this all gets to you every day you
kind of think we've reached
you know the max capacity that we can
handle and now this multi-week shutdown
in california
governor always appreciate your time
thank you sandra